alright so the skeleton of this code is
pretty much what you've already done
before but we're going to introduce a
few other things here first of all we
set this color variable to be the caller
of xhr get now this is a special thing
in JavaScript and what it does is
whoever ends up calling xhr get will be
set as this xhr get color parameter and
you can grab that as necessary next we
do the same thing that we've done this
entire time create a new xmlhttprequest
and call the open method and we check
the type if it exists then we set it
otherwise we assume by default that it
is just txt now the onload function is
where things get interesting if we set a
call back then we go ahead and try and
call it otherwise we don't do anything
now this try-catch block is something
that some of you might be familiar with
we try to do what is in this tribe luck
here and if it fails then we catch the
error and throw an exception now this is
basically just going to print out a
whole bunch of information about the
exception and this is where color comes
in as well you can see that we print out
the exception the response text and the
caller just for debugging purposes
finally we call X hrs end and that's it
and if we load this up in our browser we
can see we make both calls the first one
takes a lot less time in the second one
since it's only JSON we can see our
output JSON in the console and our song
starts